[Musique]
koné tous regardés qu'il ait pas beau la
beauté des îles à botter nous portons à
istanbul à tabarre parfois les 100 buts
ont été invités pour revisiter unique de
pays et donc nous sommes très intéressés
par les cliniques et par les curieux les
deux on va vous devrez plein petit story
on embrasse
[Musique]
marseille
et voilà au monde au monde paysan ball
je vous rappelle pas des films pour
[Musique]
aider les villes d'abord et ensuite
doublé sous ses plus beaux jours michael
a besoin propre où elle je te préviens
j'aimerais me voilà
donc là j'ai versé ma petite patte juste
comme ça avec le doseur c'est trop
pratique j'en ai sur une autre claque
voila voila il te poids libres ouais
c'est ça je vous embrasse
j'ai bientôt fini je vous fais la story
aujourd'hui de ma journée entière je
vais vous saouler et les ennemis d
imposer ça y est on est pas aimé que
hormis sur les bords du bosphore du
beaufort dans l'arctique et qui s'est
fait greffer dessus tout sa collègue
[Musique]
venue de la dernière saison hormis
connectez vous
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé que vous freine
story de ma journée voilà il reste du
rhum la doc gynéco on sera à régler on
sera carré il ya des sirop de fraise
pour un humain il ya du martini à tous
via les palettes vides tout s'arrête
tout ça il ya eu la marchandise ne sut
n'oubliez jamais comme une marche on est
dessus
[Musique]
hahaha
tout à fait
il
merci max ouais ok
t'as pas envie
colère
j'insiste vraiment sur les dangers des
surdoses en médicaments gens te
convaincre non mais c'est quoi ce clip
yeux des plages il a des réponses
peering break final on sait qu elle
dégaine arrivée massive du frérot
c'est ce mec qui faire marche arrière
notre héros arrivée massive
non c'est le meilleur c'est paul meilhat
parce qu'elle va avoir le docteur aller
à tout à l'heure
taclé fond le poulet 1
quand on vous dit qu'il faut respecter
les doses des médicaments
bon les amis
corentin a vanté sa ça faisait pas il
est pas moche mais maintenant résultat
maintenant là c'était un peu juste
passable
[Musique]